go back to Mario in the Fall's tweet he
just posted something I want to show
this go back to you he just said uh
click on it and go back yeah to see
whatever he go down go down go down he
just said yeah keep going down keep
going down keep going down uh keep going
down keep going down keep going down
there's um
he they just invited me on their live
today for 2PM keep going a little lower
keep going a little lower it's like two
hours ago you still gotta go keep going
keep going by the way who is this Mario
in the fall he's actually very good
citizen journalist online okay so today
will be more released from any
authorities the rest will be likely
prolonged to 30 days a few times Max is
180 days as investigations continues
unlikely to get bail
and they face up to 20 years in jail
that's yesterday nine hours ago is what
they were talking about okay what the
Romanian attorney was talking about you
can't get on bail when you're facing
charges for crimes that have a direct
intention both rape and traffic fall
into this category crimes that could be
punished with more than seven years of
prison both rape and traffic in five to
ten years now here's the part I just got
a couple messages from people in Romania
here's here's what couple said
um
one is uh uh uh uh please do not mention
my name I will not mention your name on
who you are but this person lives in
Romania okay he said uh he has been
connected with the Romanian Elite who is
the elite in Romania the Orthodox Church
the politicians the police he made huge
donations to the Orthodox Church however
he recently converted to Islam Romania
is one of the most Christian countries
in the world and he may have pissed off
the wrong people his conversion to Islam
was a slap in the face to many
high-profile religious persons in
Romania this is just my own Insight okay
wow good point yeah good opinion that's
one that was said now another one that
just came in right now saying it's not
going to be about rape allegations and
any of this stuff it's going to be more
about money laundering you got to be
careful with money laundering taxes any
of that that's where they get you but
but listen here's the here's the other
part if if the government really wanted
to get you really really wanted to get
you they can figure out ways to say you
didn't twenty two dollars you didn't pay
17 years ago in taxes and you know
you're short on this again there's so
many creative ways for them to come
after you if they choose to do so it's
not hard for them to do it uh uh so you
the louder you are the more targets you
got and the louder you are your biggest
insurance policies is to make sure some
of the biggest institutions in the world
have your back because behind closed
doors they got to be negotiating
Brittany Greiner how long did it take
her to get out six months of a month
almost seven it's a long time guys of
course that's not a you know and what
did U.S have to give up and The Merchant
of death well first of a horrible
negotiation nearly 10 months by the way
10 10 months oh wow horrible negotiation
on our end okay I want to know what we
would have given up for LeBron
[Music]
LeBron's got the most powerful
institutions that have his back he
wouldn't stay for a split because he has
good relationship he has good alliances
he wouldn't stay for a split second
because he's got a line call back
strategy strategy it's all in strategy
in the next move if this thing ends and
he's out he has to change his Strat he
has to take a week off and purely decide
where he's going to be building his
alliances does he stay in Romania
I think you made a great Point here
because I'm just going back uh to the
interview we had the reason that he
lives in Romania is because it has
Traditional Values he was Christian at
the time and he says that it's like the
most Christian
place in Europe and they value you know
judeo-christian values and everything
like that so what you said about the
fact that he did convert to Islam I
don't know about 30 60 days ago
that I can under I can appreciate why
the Orthodox Church of Romania views
that as a slap in the face is that what
the guy basically said in the in the
Tweet yeah because he said that imagine
you said the the Christian they're
they're running the show over there yeah
when he gets out you know where he's
moving Dubai Sweden no I don't know
about Sweden but yeah he's moving to
Dubai I I would as a Muslim a wealthy
guy he's gonna yeah Dubai would probably
be the spot I I'm curious to see what do
what what do what do you guys think will
he do any time like not not this 30 day
whatever I'm talking about will he be
will he be sent to prison in Romania I'm
curious to what people I don't know I
don't even want to speculate on that
because essentially what Pat's saying is
like look he might have done this I hope
it's not true I'm not wishing anything
bad for the dude you know good
relationship with them but
it's like it's one of those things where
it's like
like what you were saying is like the
government will do it like you can go
back and they found twenty dollars that
you didn't like report on your tax yeah
your W-2s 1099 whatever it is from 14
years ago they'll get you of course if
they want to get you they will get you
even if you are innocent oh yeah that's
the scary thing right now is that he's
poking the Bears so much you gotta stop
dude well I mean but here's the thing he
knew like dude the guy has basically
predicted everything that's gonna happen
so that goes back to my question I was
like bro you you you did what you did
you knew the consequences you already
set up he already says that the three
tiers of his of the life the Matrix um
they cancel you they put you in prison
and then they're gonna try to kill you
if you if you get out of prison do I
mean so it's like either he was doing it
to do it to get the eyeballs and become
famous and he's that guy but number two
is like are you ready to to get the real
like repercussions of your actions
because yo either he's like a modern day
you know masculine he wants men to be
man and he's sticking up for for that
generation or he's just like hey I was
just trying to get eyeballs and now it's
like oh [ __ ] this thing is this thing
has gone real so
I don't know it's gonna be an
interesting next couple days so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]